today on the matt wall show columbus day
has been increasingly replaced by
indigenous people's day we're told that
we should celebrate indigenous people
rather than columbus because columbus
was a violent man who conquered lands
that didn't belong to him and that's
mostly true but i still say we should
celebrate him and i'll explain why today
also southwest cancelled thousands of
flights this weekend right right as its
employees went on strike over its
vaccine mandates but the media and
southwest both insist that the two
issues are not connected at all plus the
family of the texas school shooter
continues to defend him even though he
brought a gun to school and shot people
and in our daily cancellation we'll talk
about one of the most nauseating one of
the most sickening espn segments ever
aired on the network and that is really
saying something we'll play that today
for you all of that and much more on the
matt wall show
[Music]
well you know i love all of my sponsors
here on the matt walsh show i love them
all equally but some are more equal than
others and that's the case with uh moiq
meat because moines that's what that's
what they're all about they're all about
delicious meat that they deliver right
to your door and that's why i love moing
with moic you can get the highest
quality meat you've ever tasted while
supporting real family farms in the
process moich delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild-caught alaskan
salmon direct to your door helping
family farms become financially
independent outside of big agriculture
their animals are raised outdoors their
fish swim wild in the ocean and moink
meat is free of antibiotics hormone
sugar all the other junk that you find
pre-packaged in the meat aisle sign up
at mointbox.com walsh to get a year of
bacon for free and then pick what
meats you want delivered with your first
box you can change what you get each
month and you can cancel any time um and
i can tell you right now the food is uh
is delicious and you don't have to be a
five-star chef like i am to to uh to
still enjoy
the meat as well join the movement today
go to moicbox.com walsh right now and
listeners to this show get free bacon
for a year
that's one year of the best bacon you'll
ever taste for a limited time spelled m
o i n k box dot com slash walsh that's
monkbox.com walsh please allow me to be
the first and perhaps at this point the
only person to wish you a happy columbus
day well i'm not the only one we have
some other columbus fans here at the
daily wire and there are more scattered
throughout the country but the number of
people who will acknowledge and show
proper appreciation for columbus or any
other of the the heroes of western
civilization
is dwindling rapidly more and more our
country is overrun by historically
illiterate halfwits who insist that we
cannot celebrate the great men of our
history because those great historical
men made the mistake of being historical
rather than modern what's more they
committed the crime of being mere men
and not angels they had flaws they were
not perfect and if they weren't perfect
then they were scum and all of their
achievements were dirt and ash amounting
to nothing that's the popular modern
attitude anyway
and it's an attitude especially
prevalent in people who themselves have
never achieved a single thing of note at
all in their lives
they've never done anything of value in
their entire lives they've contributed
absolutely nothing to the world
whatsoever and yet they feel qualified
to scoff at the achievements of the
people who made their luxurious lives
possible
they don't even see the irony in mocking
columbus for his alleged navigational
deficiencies even as these same people
can't make it a half a mile to the
walgreens down the street without the
assistance of a satellite i mean they
need a satellite a phone a car just to
make it a half mile
all of the all of the the the technology
that the world can offer them they need
just just for that trip
christopher columbus navigating
completely uncharted waters half a
millennium ago
did not have those technological
advantages he had to make his way
through the mostly unknown sea
across thousands of treacherous miles
using the stars
and dead reckoning and other techniques
that would flummox his modern critics
all of whom would be shipwrecked in
about 45 minutes if they were in the
same situation
but columbus survived the first voyage
and discovered a whole part of the globe
that was unknown to his civilization at
the time
and this is when the modern losers again
chime in with one of the two or three
bits of information that they know about
this subject all of which they acquired
from twitter memes and they announced
that columbus he didn't even mean to
discover the americas he was trying to
find asia ha what a dope
yes of course columbus didn't mean to
discover the americas you idiots
nobody knew that it existed
how does that undermine the significance
of the discovery
if some future team of astronauts
accidentally discover a life-bearing
moon of jupiter on their way to i don't
know explore pluto
should we dismiss their groundbreaking
history shaping discovery on the basis
that they originally intended to make a
different groundbreaking history shaping
discovery
would you sit back here on earth on your
couch and say what a bunch of dorks they
were trying to find pluto and
accidentally discovered extraterrestrial
life instead
perhaps you would but that says more
about you than any of the explorers who
are out changing the world while you sit
on your fat ass injecting cheese whiz
straight into your veins
over the course of columbus's voyages he
discovered many caribbean islands and
explored the coasts of south and central
america he didn't make it to what is now
the continental united states but he
made it possible
for future explorers to soon find it
and that's quite an achievement i would
say
or must he be blamed for only
discovering half of the western
hemisphere while neglecting to discover
the other half
the point with columbus is that he was
one of the men one of the primary men
to bring civilization to this side of
the globe
he planted the seeds for the society
that we all live in today
if columbus never existed
your life would be very different in
fact your life you might not exist at
all yourself
and it would be different in a much
worse way
he was a great explorer
he was not a great governor or
administrator yes he also took slaves he
executed both spaniards and indians
under his rule he uh took gold
he was not nearly as good at as leading
men on dry land as he was at leading men
while they were on the sea this was a
common flaw of explorers of that era
many of them were brilliant on their
ships but incompetent to even horrible
on solid ground magellan made it
three-quarters of the way around the
globe before getting himself killed in a
needless conflict with a tribe in the
philippines
see a certain type of man was needed to
navigate a fleet of ships across
uncharted waters
a different kind of man was needed to
manage settlements these are different
skills
but the thing is back in those days if
you were a captain of one of these ships
you had to be everything you had to play
all of these roles
you had to be an expert in in every
conceivable
area
unfortunately you know the latter type
the ones that were actually good at
managing settlements they had no way of
getting to the settlement except by
hitching a ride
with the former type and the former they
weren't often willing to seed control of
the land they had just gone through all
the trouble of discovering
that was the issue
now we can acknowledge these realities
while still honoring the achievements of
the people who shape the world we all
currently and most of us passively
occupy
here's the problem
if we're saying that the brutality and
violence of historical figures entirely
negates the good they did
and the things they achieved
then we've painted with a brush so broad
that it erases everyone and i mean
everyone
that's one of the things that makes the
push to replace columbus day with
indigenous people's day so incredibly
ridiculous
and that's a push that's almost
succeeded in fact joe biden on friday
became the first president in history to
issue an indigenous people's day
proclamation officially acknowledging
the holiday that is meant to replace
not only replace but be an apology for
columbus day
but the problem should be obvious
to anybody with an above room
temperature iq which which means that
it's not obvious to very many people
these days
if we cannot celebrate columbus day
because the european explorers and
settlers practice conquest and slavery
how can we celebrate indigenous people's
day seeing how
indigenous people practice an even more
ruthless form of conquest and slavery
despite what you may have heard
europeans did not introduce these forms
of brutality to these shores
the indian tribes had already discovered
them for themselves and often took it
several steps farther
for example the most powerful tribes in
mesoamerica would take slaves and then
add the extra step of cutting their
beating hearts out of their chests and
sometimes consuming their carcasses
not all tribes had human sacrifice but
they all lived by the law of conquest if
you wanted land you took it if you
wanted to keep it you had to defend it
if you couldn't defend it your land
would be conquered
and among indians it also meant that
you're that part of conquering land if
your land was conquered it mean that it
meant that all of your men would be
tortured and killed
and your daughters would be taken as sex
slaves
that's just the way it worked that's the
way it worked everywhere among nearly
all indigenous people
if the europeans were land thieves
they were stealing from thieves
if they were conquerors they were
conquering conquerors
if they were killers they were killing
killers
does that make it all okay
not necessarily but it does complicate
the black and white it does complicate
sort of the black and white
victim versus oppressor model that we've
come up with in modern times
and it does also raise the question as
to why
we should celebrate one group of
oppressive conquerors the indians and
not the other
see once we understand historical
context
and we see that history was a brutal
time
filled with violent people and that
every inhabited inch of the globe has
been settled through war and every line
has been drawn in blood
once we see all of that the only
sensible thing is to accept that reality
and thank god that our reality is a
little bit less bleak than that a little
bit less
and then decide who to honor and
celebrate based on their achievements
see if we focus on sin
if that's the only thing we're thinking
about
there are no winners
no one is worthy if that's all we're
focusing on
and that's the case even today
but if we focus on achievement
if that's what we're looking
how does it all shake out
i mean are we celebrating indigenous
people's day because of their
achievements
is that holiday supplanting columbus day
because the achievements of indigenous
people were greater than columbus's
achievements
well if that's the case what were their
achievements exactly
and that's a sincere question
i'm not asking it rhetorically
what were their achievements
if you're asking me to celebrate
indigenous people's day what were the
achievements of these indigenous people
what am i celebrating exactly
am i just celebrating them for existing
is that the achievement
now we know that the native tribes were
about three or four thousand years
behind european civilization in terms of
technology art philosophy government
and in pretty much every other way
i mean
the most advanced civilizations in this
part of the world were building pyramids
the most advanced ones
many other tribes hadn't even discovered
agriculture
so so what are we celebrating on
indigenous people's day
i think the proclamation from joe biden
clears things up he writes in in general
terms by the contributions of native
tribes but he doesn't list any specific
ones and then he has this he says quote
the federal government has a solemn
obligation to lift up and invest in the
future of indigenous people and empower
tribal nations to govern their own
communities and make their own decisions
we must never forget the centuries-long
campaign of violence displacement
assimilation terror wrought upon native
communities and tribal nations
throughout our country today we
acknowledge the significant sacrifices
made by native people to this country
and recognize their many ongoing
contributions to our nation
uh okay so it's not really about
contributions
it's about victim status
because we don't honor achievements
anymore if we did columbus would still
have his holiday all to himself
instead we honor victimhood
even if the victims were victimizers
themselves
even so
all that matters is who can plant their
flag the highest up on victim mountain
that's what we're supposed to celebrate
today
and it's it's twisted and backwards and
perverse
it breeds a society of passive weaklings
seeking always to become victims
themselves because that's where the
power lies
that's where affirmation and celebration
lies that's that's where you gain it
and that's the society that we're
building rather than building a society
of bold and courageous people who admire
men for their accomplishments
and seek to achieve greatness themselves
see personally i prefer the latter
approach
and that is reason enough
among many other reasons to say again
happy columbus day
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you've heard i'm sure about
hardware and software but you may not
know about bloatware bloatware is
software that is pre-loaded on a new
device that you never asked for and
could be potentially harmful and it
could slow your device down or put your
personal information at risk as well if
you find bloatware on your device
be sure to uninstall it uh it's one of
the reasons why it's so important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could harm what's yours your finances
your credit everything that's why it's
so good that there's lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats
uh things that you might not be able to
discover on your own if you're just
checking your credit score you're
checking your bank account
like if your social security number is
for sale on the dark web things like
that
you need lifelock for and if they detect
that your information has potentially
been compromised they'll send you an
alert and they also have their identity
restoration specialist on call in case
you do suffer
from identity theft nobody can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton join now and save up to 25
percent off your first year by going to
lifelock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
for 25 off
all right
so media matters we'll have some fun
with that opening segment
as we um
as we move on to this from the daily
wires so southwest airlines canceled
nearly 2 000 flights over the weekend
grounding thousands of travelers and
would-be passengers over what it
referred to as air traffic control and
weather problems
affecting its service
according to flight aware of flight
tracking service southwest airlines
canceled just over 800 flights on
saturday and delayed more than one-third
of its service
on sunday the airliner cancelled a
thousand over a thousand flights a
little over a thousand flights or 28
percent of the day's southwest flights
southwest airlines said in a statement
on twitter air traffic control issues
and disruptive weather have resulted in
a high volume of cancellations
throughout the weekend while we work to
recover our operation we appreciate your
patience as we accommodate uh affected
customers customer service wait times
are longer than usual
but some have speculated that many
flights were canceled due to a strike
among southwest pilots
the southwest airlines pilot association
which on friday asked the courts to
temporarily stop a cover 19 vaccine
mandate for members alleging a violation
of labor law
has denied the theories behind the
cancellations um
and they're saying it's also operational
difficulties
and so that's what we're getting for
everyone we know that um
there was this uh
this strike among
southwest
employees especially southwest pilots
because you know
for some reason to be a to be a pilot of
a commercial aircraft you need to have a
vaccine
not exactly sure why that's the case
so see me when i'm on a plane
especially as a as a highly anxious
flyer myself
and i'm sitting there in the you know in
the in the um
in the cabin the only
thing
i'm worried about is whether that the
pilot
is really good at flying planes that's
the only thing i care about
i don't care about any other
qualification
i just want i just want to know that you
have the best of the best the person
flying the plane he's doing it because
he's the best one for the job
that's the only thing
whether he's vac i don't care what he's
vaccinated or not vaccinated it doesn't
doesn't make any difference to me
i think probably most customers feel the
same
but um
they have this strike and then they
they're they're still canceling flights
all these flights grounded and you see
you can see some of the uh some of the
videos you go online
of just turmoil in these uh
in these airport terminals all across
the country because all these flights
are being cancelled
the strange thing is that yeah they're
saying it's well it's operational
difficulties it's weather
well the weather has been last few days
pretty nice in
in most places around the country
and if that was the case then you would
think you would see
um all of the other air usually when
there's cancellations and they're
grounding flights because of weather if
you've ever if you've been in an airport
when there's bad storm coming through
and they're grounding flights
uh
you know how it works you can't just go
over to another airline they're
grounding all the flights
because this is coming from air traffic
control
so air traffic control is grounding only
southwest flights because of weather
that doesn't make a lot of sense
uh the daily wire continues here with
more information about this says none of
the three other major airlines in the
u.s came close to the number of
southwest cancelled flights um although
american airlines also cancelled a
sizable number 149 are the equivalent of
five percent of sunday service as of
sunday evening
that's still like a tenth of what of
what
southwest canceled united airlines
cancelled nine flights on sunday and
delta airlines cancelled three flights
so you've got over a thousand
versus three
and this is supposed to be weather
related
now it seems
it seems pretty clear to
anyone who's thinking rationally about
this what's going on
there was a strike they can't they don't
have the pilots they don't have the
personnel to fly the planes and that's
why they're all being grounded
and yet there is this
once again this
full-on soviet-style propaganda campaign
happening
from southwest and the media
or they're just lying to our face
there's a there's a there's a strike
announced among pilots because of the
vaccine mandate next thing you know
flights are grounded
thousands only among southwest
flights
and they tell us
that's got nothing to do with it it's a
totally separate issue
they're lying about it why would they
lie about this
that's kind of an interesting question
because you i mean usually the media
especially they're eager to tell us
about
people you know protesting or upset
about vaccine mandates
if there's a protest or a rally
somewhere the media is it has no problem
give showing us the images of that
telling us about it
but why would they be especially
reluctant to acknowledge
uh airline pilots
who are protesting over the mandate
well i think it's because it's harder to
caricature see the caricature they have
of people who are against vaccine
mandates and of course they equate that
with being anti-vaxx even though the two
things are not the same necessarily at
all
i mean i i would i would venture to say
the vast majority of people who are
anti-vaccine mandate are not necessarily
anti-backs
um
but usually the caricature is that these
are all a bunch of dumb
you know uh
like high school dropouts and that's a
bunch of we're all a bunch of dumb
rednecks and and that's that's all those
are the only people that care about the
mandates
anti-science don't understand well
it's hard to do that with airline pilots
these are obviously highly intelligent
highly skilled highly educated people
and they have to have a pretty good
grasp of science maybe not medical
science but you know
it's hard to be an anti-science airline
pilot
you're not going to be in that job for
very long and you're going to take down
a lot of people with you probably
literally speaking if you're
anti-science as an airline pilot so it's
it's that's a harder thing to character
so they'd rather just ignore they know
they don't want you to know that that
airline pilots are against the vaccine
mandate too they don't want you to know
that
and yet this is exactly what needs to
happen
people
saying we will not comply saying we're
just not going to do it we're not going
to go along with it
and
and refusing and that refusal causes
real consequences
i mean southwest is hurting right now
and there's consequences for for lots of
people who are not i mean they're
passengers who need to get on a plane
and go somewhere
and it's causing inconvenience for them
but it's a necessary inconvenience
this is a good uh this is a good model
for everyone and that's another reason
why they don't want us to know about it
because it shows us the kind of even if
we're not airline pilots it shows us the
power that we have if we simply say no
here's the line i've drawn it not gonna
let you cross it
i'm not gonna comply with it
when you do that
here's what can happen
it is a good model and they don't want
us to see that model
all right let's uh
on the issue of mandates if you guys are
ready to
maybe have your cold callous hearts
warmed a little bit i don't play a lot
of heartwarming stuff on this show it's
not really it's not really my brand but
here's a video of a mom telling her son
as he uh arrives home from school
holding his mask in his hand uh telling
her that she took this his school to
court over the mask mandates and and won
and uh it's just pretty powerful to see
the
little kids reaction watch this
can i tell you something
so
there were some parents
of bentonville school some of my friends
who took the school to court
okay they took him to court
saying that they can't mandate masks
and we won
tomorrow baby you don't have to wear
oh it's gonna be so weird
siri says he says it's gonna be so he
says it in a positive way of course the
kids overcome with emotion doesn't have
to wear the mask to school anymore
um
and you you could see why he would feel
that way i mean i i would feel the same
way if i was forced to wear a mask for
seven hours a day
five days a week
uh and i finally was told that i could
take it off i think i'd have the same
amount of relief but you hear him say
there it's gonna oh it's gonna be so
weird not wearing the mask
even though he's happy he doesn't have
to wear it
uh
and and this is with a kid who still has
his head on straight
fortunately that he that he doesn't want
to wear it
and even for him it's like the idea of
not wearing the mask is kind of weird
because this has been this this has been
imposed on him
so much
you think and then you think about the
kids who
and there are some kids who
will would be upset to to if they're
told that they couldn't wear them
getting rid of the mask man it doesn't
mean that you can't wear it
but there are some kids if they were
told that they can't wear the mask
anymore they'd be upset and afraid
not because they need it but because
they have become so psychologically
dependent on it and they've been
convinced
by the abuse of adults in their life
that the air itself is toxic and if they
breathe it they might die
so you see this kind of conditioning
even with a kid who has resisted it up
until now
but more importantly what you see from
there is that this is you know this is
no small thing
telling kids to wear the mask every day
i guess the the mask cultists those of
us who say we don't want to wear the
mask
we're accused of being petty
and weak
like somehow we're the cowards
i i love that the the way they flip that
one around somehow um they don't want to
leave their house without without a
muzzle on their face
and we're the cowards
if we're willing to if if we're willing
to walk outside and breathe fresh air
we're the cowards for not wearing it
that's how they want to flip it around
are they going to say that to that child
there who doesn't want to wear it
anymore
i guess so
all right next this is from the new york
post it says the texas teen who injured
four people when he allegedly opened
fired at his high school at his high
school
celebrated his release from jail with a
welcome home party
even as one of the victims remains in a
coma
timothy simpkins 18 we've told you about
this case attends timberview high school
in arlington
posted 75 000 bail then headed to home
confinements
and um
one of his victims is still in a coma
there was another teacher that was shot
in the back
who's fortunately was is out of the
hospital was not was not
was not critically wounded
but then he gets home and they have and
their images there are pictures of this
online they've got balloons and they
throw him a coming home party welcome
home party from jail after bringing a
gun to school and shooting someone
and here they are
you don't you like never see this with
school shootings i think it's probably
the first time
that the medi that the the family has
come out and
unapologetically explicitly
defended their kid who brought a gun to
school and fired it and shot people
so here they are outside their house
locking arms and once again offering
this full-throated defense of their
school shooter son listen
there's a video that's all out on social
media and it shows that he was being
attacked
it wasn't just one person
that would attack him and bully him
taking his money
harassing him due to the fact because he
had more things than maybe others
it takes us all
it takes us all to stand together about
this bullying it could have been a
situation where he took the other turn
and decided to commit suicide what the
decision that he made taking the gun
we're not justifying that
that was not right but he was trying to
protect himself
yeah let's let's stand together
let's lock arms and stand with the
school shooter
who brought a gun to school
showing some uh some premeditation there
and then by all reports by all accounts
fired the gun after the fight had been
broken up that's why that's how the
teacher got shot
in the back
because he was breaking up the fight
standing in front of the other kid
and then pulls the gun out i guess out
of his backpack
and starts firing it
that's not self-defense that again is
revenge
on someone who you feel has bullied you
and maybe the other kid was a bully
but you know this should not be a
shocking or controversial thing to say
um it's not okay for a student in high
school to shoot someone who bullied them
i i would hope we could all agree on
that
but it seems as though we can't
i know this like if there's any larger
conversation
that we have
related to bullying
because of this case
and i'm not sure that there needs to be
but if there is the conversation should
not be about bullying i want to say this
again because this is a really important
point
as much as we hear about the bullying
epidemic in our schools and how bullying
is so bad it's so terrible now you know
there's a bullying
when people in my parents generation
went to school
there was no talk of a bullying epidemic
nobody was talking about that does that
mean that there was no bullying at all
that nobody got bullied no of course
they did
in fact if you listen to stories of
people in that generation and older or
if you're in that generation yourself
you could probably attest to this
but oftentimes the bullying was
significantly worse than anything these
kids have to deal with today
and part of that is that there wasn't
this uh zero tolerance against bullying
thing and
in some schools anyway the teachers were
not as uh
as vigilant as as uh
about it
um
and it was seen as more of a kind of
normal part of growing up for better or
worse that's how it was seen
so there was there was a lot more leeway
given to kids back then and uh you just
you hear you hear plenty of stories
about the kinds of things that kids
did to each other in schools back then
and it's oftentimes much worse
and certainly the the fights and the
violence could be a lot worse
now you didn't have you didn't hear
about the school shootings we'll get to
that in a second
plus fist fights and everything i mean i
mean these days in in in most cases
there's a fist fight in school it's
broken up right away
and then a lot of times both kids are
going to be punished for it
which is which is absurd and of itself
like we're not going to take into
account who the aggressor was or who
started it like that doesn't matter at
all
but that's what they've done they've
taken a zero tolerance policy that
didn't exist you know 30 40 years ago
and uh previous to that
so bullying is not new
it's it's a it's a part of the human
condition
or people want to assert their dominance
over others
and especially if someone is is insecure
about themselves they want to make
themselves feel better they want to
elevate themselves by stepping on
someone who they uh
perceive to be weaker than themselves
okay so we know that bullying isn't new
i don't think there's any evidence that
it's worse than it is now
and yet you have
school shootings in response to it
um
why is that
i think it's because it's not that our
that our kids
face worse bullying now than they ever
did
it's that our kids are worse
at dealing with
and coping with the bullying
that's the problem that's what we should
be talking about
rather than constantly having this
conversation about how to stop bullying
how do we stop you're never going to
stop it
it's always going to be there
even if you could put a stop to the
physical bullying you're still gonna
have the psychological bullying which
which uh which can be worse
especially among girls
the ways the way that they can treat
each other
absolute cruelty sometimes
just trying to break someone down
it's one thing to get punched in the
nose that's no fun but to be
tormented and broken down
psychologically
over the course of months weeks and
months and years as some
kids face in school especially girls you
know that that could be a lot worse
but rather than talking about putting a
stop to that which we're never going to
be able to completely do
why aren't we talking about
um equipping our kids to better handle
the bullying
if this kid was not even a kid he's 18
years old
and the claim is he was being bullied by
a 15 year old
and also the claim is that he was
getting bullied
because he drives a nice car and wears
nice clothes to school
and if that's the case then bullying is
that's certainly one change
uh with bullying in recent years
i mean when i went to school you weren't
getting bullied for having nice clothes
or a nice car the bowling would go the
other way
so maybe things have flipped around i
don't know
but he's bringing a gun and he's
shooting someone then this is a per this
is a man
who is uh incapable of dealing
with these kinds of things
and so what we should be talking about
is how we better equip our kids to deal
with it
you know she mentioned suicide as like
that was the only other option shoot the
kid or shoot himself
we would certainly hope that there would
be more options than that
and it's your job as a parent to make
sure your kids know that there are other
options
but we also know that's that that sues
adolescent suicide is uh
really is an epidemic
and would seem to be much more common
now
than it was in years past that's another
thing that you you don't hear about from
older generations
you talk to people in older generations
they'll tell you like that was
you never going to middle school in high
school you didn't hear about kids
killing themselves
now you do
and a lot of that goes back again to
kids not being equipped
with the tools to deal with this and
it's this is not this is not me saying
oh kid's a bunch of weaklings and wimps
that's not the point
i mean kids are kids
the problem is that these days they're
in this they're they're totally
enveloped
in this pure culture that they can't
escape from that oftentimes at home you
know we're not giving them the the
ability uh to escape from it
where they go to school and they're with
their peers all day
and then and then they come home and
they're on their phones and they're on
their computers
and they're still connected to their
peers
so they've got the peer culture online
they've got the peer culture at school
and it's in it and it completely
suffocates them they can't get away from
it there's no break
at least before the internet you know
you went to school maybe there was
bullying maybe there was this and that
maybe you weren't in the in this like in
the social stratosphere that you wanted
to be
in but then you went home and you were
home
and you had that break that respite at
least
now kids don't even have that so they
become understandably because they're
kids and there are a lot of adults who
are like this too it's very easy to fall
into this they become totally
um dependent on their their peers
affirmation and desperate for it
because they can't escape their peers
and they feel like if i don't have that
affirmation if i don't have that
acceptance
uh from my peers then my life then then
my whole life is destroyed
because my peers are my life that's all
i have
um
i think the
the goal should be to orient our kids
away from this seeking of of of pure
affirmation all the time to orient them
more back to ourselves to adults
to get them to care about
no i mean approval from your peers
especially in high school that's that's
fleeting
okay and they're going to approve of you
if you conform with them and if you're
if you're just like them that's how you
get approval
um
what you should care about is as our
parents we love you
um that's the kind of thing you should
care about how do we get to orient our
kids
that way one of the ways
like i'm always preaching is to get them
off take the phones away
don't let them come home and sit on the
computer or on their phones for for the
next seven hours
give them a break give them an oasis
away from all this stuff
help them to discover a life outside of
it
that's one thing we could be doing
that's a conversation we could be having
but instead we're just talking about
bullying
all right um
what else do we got here
so i wanted to mention this as well it's
from the daily wire it says model emily
radishkowski said this week that she
stayed silent about a groping allegation
against musician robin thicke for nearly
a decade because she feared coming
forward forward would derail her dreams
of becoming famous
her new book my body detailed the
alleged groping incident on set of the
blurred lines video in 2013
according to rajkowski
in her account an intoxicated thick
groped the model's bare breasts without
consent
she said
i was an unknown model and if i'd spoken
out or complained i would not be where i
am today i would not be famous
she said quote i wrote a book about the
evolution of my politics and that
includes a lot of different experiences
from my career and my life and the way
that i felt and thought about those
experiences has evolved i hope people
are able to read the essay and
understand the nuance behind these kinds
of situations
okay so emily rajkowski is a model went
uh to perform in this music video
blurred lines which by the way that song
if i remember correctly is basically an
ode to date rape
and um so she went to you know and to
dance nude in this video uh celebrating
date rape
and uh big shock she ended up getting
groped by the guy that was singing it
but rather than speak out then
and try to protect other future victims
she said nothing because she wanted to
be famous
and then waited until she had a book to
sell to tell everybody about it
but but but we're not supposed to put
any blame on her whatsoever there's no
criticism of her
she she's admitting that she was willing
to endure that simply because she wanted
to be famous
and now in order to sell a book she
tells a story
how about a little bit of responsibility
that this is one of the many problems
with the metoo movement which still sort
of
sort of lingers on
as this you know undead zombie sort of
lingering there wandering across the
landscape
one of the many problems
is that you had all these stories from
women
you know making claims 10 20 things
happen 10 20 15 years ago
uh
that they they admitted for for their
own professional ambition they kept
themselves letting other people be
victimized
and now they come out and say it
like there's there's there's no
accountability or responsibility for
the women in those cases
and there should be
i mean how is this story from
from emily ratajkowski that she she
comes out and tells us proudly
how is this not a story of incredible
cowardice
and selfishness
and she didn't even try to come up with
a with a a better sounding reason she
just said i want her to be famous and
that's why i didn't say anything
and if he went on to grope uh
two dozen other women so be it
uh i i find that
robin thicke's behavior
is gross
that's also gross
all right let's move now to reading the
youtube comments
who's rocking polka dotted flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
okay this from roxanne says matt i would
have to disagree with you about men not
caring about their future wives income
times have changed many men want a woman
who can earn her own money so she can
contribute significantly
uh yeah i mean that might be something
that men prefer
i i never did i mean i never cared about
that i never even thought about it
i never thought about my my wife's
income earning potential it could never
cross my mind and i didn't care at all
but maybe for some men it does cross
their mind it's it's kind of when
they're like listing all the things they
like
about their future wife maybe that makes
it on the list
but i don't believe that any men are
actually making decisions based
primarily on that
so put another way put another way for
for any straight man
a beautiful woman
comes along who he connects with and he
can trust
he's going to choose her right
no matter her career career ambitions or
lack thereof
that
100 he's going to choose her
there's there's not any man who's going
to say yeah there's this woman she's
beautiful i'm attracted to her uh i
connect with her i can trust her
she's into me
um but you know i don't think i'm
interested in going forward this
relationship because uh because she
really doesn't have any career ambitions
no man is saying that
whereas there are plenty of women who
who make those are who who may in fact
make a calculation like that
they might say look there's this guy i'm
very attracted to him he's a nice guy we
seem to connect i trust him um but
he's you know he lays around all day he
doesn't have a job he doesn't he does he
doesn't seem interested in getting a job
you know he does he doesn't have a lot
of ambition he has no plans for the
future i don't know if he's going to be
any kind of provider
i think a woman's going to think about
that and balance all of it and uh she's
very likely to say well you know
this is not the one the search continues
no man is making that calculation i can
guarantee you that
uh let's see what else we got april says
let's go brandon
yes
i mean we're all big fans of brandon so
i will say as well uh let's go brandon
let's go ryan says matt are you planning
to watch the new uh bond movie uh
i'm i'm really not
at at this point
i mean really really i'm all franchise
films i think are out the window
and i've liked a lot of the bomb
especially the the daniel craig bond
movies but
especially the the
hollywood blockbuster franchise films
all of them
have been hopelessly infiltrated by the
woke pc nonsense and i i can't stomach
it
my tolerance for all that stuff has gone
down not up
you'd think that your tolerance would
increase as you're usually that's how
tolerance works is you're exposed to
things more and more your tolerance
increases but i'm having the the
opposite experience
where i can't deal with it at all the
the moment
there's there is even one single thing
that i notice that's been injected into
the script
for purposes of politically correct box
checking
the moment that happens
i hate the movie and i don't want to
watch it anymore
that's how sick of it i am and i i'm
perhaps unfairly
i'm assuming that there's at least some
of that in this bond movie there's gotta
be and so that's why
i just have no interest
uh let's see numskull says matt is
officially canceled for cruelty to the
bachmann's warbler well you know what
the bachmann's warbler can go to hell
and so can you
well not really but you are banned from
the show
um
let's see nick says i don't mind your
lack of interest in non-human animal
extinction matt but as a fellow
misanthrope shouldn't you be equally
disinterested in the decline of the
human species
uh no nick because i'm a human
chauvinist and i fully admit that
i actually prefer my own species
believe it or not
i like my own species i prefer it
i think that my species is superior to
every other species on earth
i i think that's the most natural way to
feel that's how we should all feel
it is
extremely depraved and twisted and
perverse
so like prefer other species to your i'm
sure if we could talk to any other
species they would say the same about
their own speech but we can't talk to
them or have any kind of conversation
and not just because they lack vocal
cords but because they lack any kind of
self-awareness or consciousness and so
they can't they can't even have these
sorts of thoughts
just another reason why we're superior
okay
and finally patrick says matt can you
name just one animal you do like
um i'll give you more than one cows pigs
chickens
i like them all on my plate
so i am an i'm an animal lover in a
certain way you see well i'm very
excited to tell you about our daily wire
special today because you know like we
talked about in the opening it's not
often you can say that one man changed
the course of history in a positive way
and today we remember
of course the one man one of the men who
did the great navigator and fearless
explorer christopher columbus he was a
man whose bravery persistence and skill
helped create the america that we know
and love today that's why despite the
anti-history peddled by the left to
smear the name of the great italian
navigator we're going to celebrate him
today so columbus unlocked the greatest
continent and we're letting you unlock
the greatest content for 20 35 off today
uh nice just head to dailywire.com
subscribe and enter code columbus to get
35 off and celebrate a legend who made
the greatest continent possible i mean
you could say
that we are in many ways on par
with uh with christopher columbus he had
the continent we have the content
tomato tomato really
also here's another thing that's great
tomorrow tuesday october 12th we're
taking backstage to an entirely new
level instead of the usual daily wire
studio we'll be live streaming our
conversation on stage at the famous
ryman auditorium right here in nashville
doing what we do best making sense this
will be an event and a live stream
unlike any other we've done before and
we're thrilled to be able to share it
with you all plus we'll be uh making
some extremely exciting announcements
which you will not want to miss so be
sure to tune in
join myself ben shapiro candace jeremy
bourne michael knowles andrew clavin and
our live audience for backstage like
never before tomorrow's live stream will
begin at 8 30 pm eastern 7 30 pm central
so head to dailywire.com or daily wire
youtube to catch the show now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to cancel randy
moss moss is a former nfl wide receiver
wide receiver and a current espn sports
analyst we already know that most espn
sports analysts are far left weirdos but
the other thing to understand is that
most espn sports analysts
are embarrassed about being espn sports
analysts they seem to think that it's
kind of silly and frivolous to simply
talk about sports every day and you can
decide whether you agree with their
self-assessment or not but their way of
dealing with this insecurity is to
pretend that they're part of some kind
of greater and more profound cultural
conversation
due both to their political slant and
this need to overcompensate
they're always eager to make mountains
out of mole hills they're always looking
for places where the events on the
football field might intersect with
larger societal issues
the problem for them
is that the two things rarely do
intersect which means that they have to
work a lot harder to draw the connection
and speaking of mole hills it was
revealed last week in a stunning and
earth-shattering expose in the wall
street journal
that current raiders head coach john
gruden sent an email 10 years ago where
he made fun of another guy for having
big lips
and the other guy's black which of
course makes it not only racist but a
hate crime of historic proportions
john gruden stands alongside history's
greatest monsters hitler polpot donald
trump all because he were marked on the
size of another guy's lips
now for a little background gruden was
himself a commentator on espn at the
time that this email was sent in 2011
he was upset about a lockout in the nfl
that was poised to short-circuit the
upcoming season
and gruden put much of the blame for
whatever reason um on executive director
of the nfl players association demoris
smith
venting his frustration in a private
email grunden wrote quote
dumb morris smith has lips the size of
michelin tires
that was it
that's what he wrote 10 years later
and this one sentence has led to great
controversy and backlash and people
calling for him to be fired and
everything else
now gruden has of course apologized
publicly and profusely for making the
comment about the guy's lips he says
that he didn't mean it in a racist way
in fact he says that he meant that smith
has rubber lips hence the michelin
reference which is an expression that
means somebody is lying so he thought
that smith was lying about this whole
lockout situation
um gruden has issued several statements
assuring the public that he's not racist
that he doesn't have a quote racist bone
in his body
that he's deeply profoundly profusely
sorry for all the you know for all the
uh
millions of people who've been somehow
hurt by a mild insult he wrote in a
private email 10 years ago
he's said all this of course it doesn't
matter at all nobody cares about the
apology they still want him to be fired
for demoris smith's part he took a bold
and heroic stance when reached by the
wall street journal this is what this is
the statement that he gave he said quote
this is not the first racist comment
that i've heard and it probably will not
be the last
this is a thick skin job for someone
with dark skin just like it always has
been for many people who look like me
and work in corporate america you know
people are sometimes saying things
behind your back that are racist just
like you see people talk and write about
you using thinly coded and racist
language racism like this comes from the
fact that i'm at the same table as they
are and they don't think someone like
who looks like me belongs i'm sorry my
family has to see something like this
but i would rather they know
i will not let it define me
how inspiring
now if that were me
and the wall street journal contacted me
about an insult that some guy had said
about me to some other guy in an email
in the year 2011
my statement would have been something
like uh what
why are you asking me about this
he said my lips were big
in the year 2011
okay
and
that would have been my statement but
that's only because i'm an amateur
demoris smith is a professional he was
ready to milk this particular cow for
all it's worth and that brings us
finally to randy moss moss was part of
the sunday nfl countdown show on sunday
morning where typically they're supposed
to talk about the upcoming games and
give their mostly arbitrary predictions
for which team is going to win and how
many yards various players are going to
gain and so on
but this whole matter of the email and
the lips lipgate as i've come to to to
know it um provided the assembled cast
with an opportunity to have a very
important conversation and they always
want to have very important
conversations
and randy moss more than any of them was
ready for it listen to this
obviously there's gonna be a lot of
emotional responses to this teddy i i
hear you saying basically if you were in
that locker room today you kind of just
put your head down and you think of him
as the leader in terms of the decision
maker but not necessarily a leader you
respect i'm curious from your
perspective randy if you were in that
locker room today would you be able to
play for him
you know to speaking on teddy teddy's
point you know
basically you hear us talk about we got
work to do we got a job to do and that's
to provide for our families and and and
teddy hit it right right on the head of
just putting your head down and going
playing football you know i i speak
about the game of football i fell in
love with the game of football sam is
six years old and
i get emotional talking about it because
of
situations like this
my civil rights were taken were were
kind of messed with in high school over
the color of my skin and now being able
to play 14 years in the national
football league
to have something like this of a leader
we talk about leadership we give guys
these big contracts
because they want to be able to lead 70
men coaches equipment staff and managers
to the number one goal and that's to win
the championship and for us to be moving
back and not forwarding 21st century
like i said man
national football league this hurts me
the clock is ticking man
it's a good thing i wasn't in the room
for that panel not that they would
invite me on a sunday
nfl countdown panel but
how can you even keep a straight face i
would have to interrupt and say dude are
you what are you are you crying
are you crying right now
no i didn't get confused by the way and
play a clip from another conversation i
know you might be wondering
you're looking at that and you're
listening to that and you're thinking
well hold on no this must be a
conversation from another time when
somebody shot randy moss's dog or
punched his grandma or caused him
offense or harm in some other
significant way that would explain why
he was so emotional
but no
they're really just talking about the
email from 10 years ago about a guy's
lips and not even his own lips
randy moss is in tears he's actually
crying
because some guy wrote a private email
to some other guy making fun of a third
guy's lips
10 years ago
and to make this all the more grotesque
but also hilarious
moss says that he wants to move forward
and his way of moving forward is to have
a public meltdown over something someone
said 10 years ago
that's how we move forward is by is by
is is by sifting through
private emails
sent during the obama administration
that's how we move forward as a society
really
and this is supposed to be a football
pregame show
people are tuning in to watch guys
pummel each other at full speed and
cause traumatic brain injuries and the
lead-in act for that show features a man
crying about an insult that wasn't even
directed at him
but it's not over um there are other
people on this panel and they all want
to show off their dramatic acting chops
also let's keep listening
i can play for you but i'd rather not
okay i'd rather not do it but if i have
to do it i will
and it's just because i have other
people that i have to provide for right
but i'd rather not do it yeah but it
we've done it before in different
situations we are all mentally tough
people in that locker room but it's
something you'd rather not do yeah so
this is what i think about it's like
randy's sitting up here feeling this way
from a distance
i can't imagine a guy in that locker
room today trying to play a football
game feeling that way with a heavy heart
how i don't know i don't know how what
max matt or rex i would love to hear
your perspective what should the nfl do
right now you see this response and you
guarantee there's there's a version of
this response in that locker room what
should they do how do you make this
right how does john gruden make this
right at this point or is it a lost
cause
i'm at a loss for solutions but i think
the the answer to that question probably
comes from somewhere inside that locker
room
see this is why i said
i don't want female football analysts
and i'm referring to all of them at the
table there
i have to remind you again they're still
talking about the lips
and and um i i wonder if we were to
search through their emails from the
last 10 years
what would we find
would we find things at least as
offensive and and insulting
as uh you know making fun of a guy's
lips
what would we find
why don't why don't they give us the
passwords to all their gmail why don't
they go come on the show next sunday
give us the passwords to their gmail
accounts let us let us go look at all of
the emails they've sent for the last 10
years
can we find something worse than that
while they're crying about an email like
i said 10 years ago
were they sending worse emails i bet you
they were
randy moss has been accused of domestic
violence in the past and arrested for
battery
has he been a total gentleman in his
private communications
i mean i wonder what what emails and
text messages he has sent
to and about the women who have made
these accusations against him
i wonder
i wonder something else earlier this
year nba star kevin durant sent a whole
string of expletive-laden messages to
the actor michael rappaport
and the whole what led to that doesn't
even matter he but kevin durant an nbi
nba superstar
threatens violence
he uses anti-white slurs he uses
anti-gay slurs
and this were these were messages he
sent
to someone
in reference to them
this year not 10 years ago
were there any tearful segments on espn
about that
if i were to go back and look would i
find a whole panel of sports analysts
reduced to tears consoling each other
over the trauma that kevin durant's
words inflicted upon them
i don't think so
what about randy moss did he have
anything to say about kevin durant
again no
and that's because this is all a game
i mean randy moss doesn't play the game
of football anymore
but he does play this game
you know he's he has gone
from the game of football
to the victimhood olympics
and he is man and he has gotten so good
and he was a great football player no
nothing could take that from him
and it turns out he is great at
victimhood olympics too
randy moss is the randy moss of the
victimhood olympics
when he has managed
to make himself the victim
of an email that someone sent 10 years
ago making fun of another guy
incredible
and yet even so i must say that today
randy moss is cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening
happy columbus day again
and godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
two indiana children suffer heart
problems after accidentally being
injected with a covid vaccine joe biden
issues a first ever indigenous people's
day proclamation
from the white house and the new york
times says we need a new american flag
because they want a new american nation
check it out on the michael knowles show